[Music]
okay everybody i'm so excited today
because i am joined by margaret cho
aka margot and ryan hanson aka dennis
and good on paper on netflix this
wednesday
how are you guys doing today we're doing
great great thank you
oh no problem so my first question is
for margaret
margaret the amount of dialogue you
rattled off so effortly in this film
while being hysterical blew me away
i'm wondering was that all scripted or
is there some improv in there
it was all scripted eliza wrote such a
beautiful script and um
you know i wanted to do it justice and
um certainly
it's something that is always a
challenge to like
like do monologues or whatever but i
loved being able to do it and um i loved
being in this it was a lot of fun
yeah no it was it was so fun to watch
and now ryan your character was so
interesting to me of dennis was there
any characters in media that like
inspired your portrayal of dennis well i
don't know if there's any characters
necessarily
but we um eliza having really gone
through this with that real guy
you know she really crafted in in the in
the script and
you know personal anecdotes that she
told me about and
the teeth helped i got to wear these a
little
a little pad in my gut that i already
have a gut but whatever
um that helps kind of craft this this
guy and it was a blast to play yeah
no you absolutely crush it now what i
also love in this film too
is margaret you and eliza have such
great chemistry together
and it seems like though you're always
on the same wavelength as scene partners
how do you guys kind of get to that
level like were you guys friends before
this like how are you so comfortable
well yeah we're friends before the film
and um
i'm a big fan of hers both her comedy
and her acting in her writing
so it was just very easy to do i really
am
so invested in her as an artist
so i really enjoyed the opportunity to
do it
yeah no and it's so fun to watch you two
just go at it on screen and then
i was gonna ask you to ryan what's
interesting about your character being
in a comedy
it's still you playing a pretty serious
part so are you approaching
the role as if you would if you were
playing any other role in like a drama
yeah i i think so like you know it's
it's on the page right there and like i
said eliza gave me so many um tips like
if there was a a line i thought i would
say like that she'd be like no
i think it's this guy would say like
this like that so you just kind of
approach it like that
and the comedy is on on the on the page
right there and
you know my guy's not the funniest guy
at all but he's just a creep really
but um yeah no but it's so it's so great
to watch and it it does add to the humor
of the film
now margaret you produced and started an
amazing horror short recently
i have to ask will we see more horror
from you soon
oh yes i love the horror genre it's like
my favorite
so to me it's really exciting to um
be able to step in and do more so yes
for sure
okay great that that's really exciting
to hear and then
ryan i'm going to ask you the million
dollar question for everyone watching
this why should we
watch good on paper when it comes out
wednesday you should watch
good on paper because it is a true story
based on a lie
that eliza actually lived through and
you get to see her stand up comedy
in it and also this wonderful creepy
beautiful story of friendship and
comedy love it and we get to see you
wear
you know fake teeth which is always
great um
and thank you guys so much margaret ryan
for joining me today and everyone please
check out this film it's great
it's good on paper on netflix this
wednesday thank you so much and hope to
talk to you guys again in the future one
day
thanks steve thank you you buddy have a
good one